foreign
let's go to April in Fort Wayne Indiana
you know what's up April
hi Dr John I don't know why I just did
that uh West Texas accent in Fort Wayne
Indiana what is the accent of Fort Wayne
Indiana
I feel like we have no accent there's
just corn here
incredible all right so what's up April
so my question is how do I support my
son and his choice to have or not have a
relationship with his bio dad's family
after his dad committed suicide
whoa whoa whoa
yeah cheers
walking me through this that was I
didn't see that curveball coming
okay sorry no I think it's hey you you
get a prize it's it's rare that I'm like
wait what I thought you were gonna say
he's dipping again or something so no
this sounds uh very much a left turn
okay so
um your son's dad took his died by
Suicide right were y'all married
no okay so we had his dad and I had him
when we were in high school okay and his
dad was really involved for like the
first year okay and then we didn't see
him again
oh okay until I went to the funeral so
geez okay how long ago did he pass away
so it's been a few years good so it's
kind of been like a build up I guess to
this point
um he killed himself two days before my
son turned five
today is the fourth birthday
and of course as soon as he died then
his family came out of the woodwork
because he hadn't seen them either and
they really wanted to have a
relationship with my son of course
and
I was young so I kind of just took the
advice I was given from people that were
well-meaning but they had never been
through this sure
um which is kind of why I'm calling you
because I need really good advice sure
for maybe an outsider my son is now 13.
so so what advice did you follow did you
connect him with his extended family or
did you yeah okay started we started out
we came up with they wanted him every
other holiday and we'd kind of work out
in between that was really good for a
few years and he didn't know them
no he did not because that was part of
the juggle too is trying to introduce
him like we kind of went slowly
introducing him it was hard to explain I
had
I had started dating someone else okay
so when he was two we started dating
when we turned three we moved in
together but as far back as he can
remember that is his dad
the person that you used to are you
still with that person now yeah okay
we've been married 10 years okay so
that's his dad
yeah that is his dad he has no memories
at all of his dad which I think is kind
of one thing that's leading us to the
point we are right now
um which is his bio family has slowly
started to kind of back out
um and he is also slowly backing out
but it's Christmas this week and so
they're calling now because they would
like to see him for Christmas Even
though they haven't seen him all year
yeah and have only talked to him a few
times
he does not want to go he has been very
um forward with me we have a really good
relationship with him and I probably
because I was so young and we really
grew up together but he's very open we
have a very good him and I line of
communication he feels comfortable
telling me exactly how he feels
um so I know his big issue
um on why he chooses I just don't know
if I should be like hey you really need
to go forward with this or if it's okay
to say hey it's fine take a break from
that relationship for a while absolutely
yes
um here's what's happening right like
when he's six seven eight
going to spend time young kids
especially not all of them because
people can be listening to me like not
my kid kids are great when they have to
at putting on a brave face and smiling
and also the novelty of new adults who
are kind and doting and loving can be
um can really fill a kid's sales okay
and give them some some real propulsion
forward my daughter
um uh Josephine she she
had a babysitter a few a few months ago
and the babysitter had to go home and
check on some things well at home was
the babysitter's mom and the
babysitter's grandmother they all ended
up going out to a park together and at
the end of the day that grandmother said
well it looks like I just got myself a
new granddaughter and Josephine my
daughter is Mayhem she's hilarious to be
around and if she's if you're in her
good graces she is like a magnet she's
incredible
she has retold that story a thousand
times
right of how this these these other
adults took her in and were like you're
I got a new Grant right she's told that
story over and over and over I tell you
that to tell you the age that we're
talking about here the developmental
stages five six seven eight
they're wired for doting they're wired
for just smiling and scanning and
they're wired for adults who say you're
welcome here
when they get to be 11 12 13 they begin
to understand what's actually going on
okay they can also begin to sense
oh you are using me because you're not
okay
and there's one thing he has expressed
to me he says I feel like the
relationship is
contingent on their grief yes and I hate
that he feels that way well he's 12 and
13 and 14 and 15 year olds are 16 year
olds
and I I think we could go back on in
evolutionary psychology and kind of work
through it but they are their their
sonar is incredibly precise they feel it
that's why kids when they're responsible
for their parents
like don't make dad mad don't they they
they create entire new Pathways for
their life that ends up in in adulthood
right so your son is very on to it he
gets it he also wants to honor you
because y'all are close and he also
doesn't want to be a jerk is that fair
right so he feels stuck
um here's another thing he's doing right
now
his biological he's going to start
asking as he goes through puberty and
Beyond he's going to start asking who am
I in a profound way
he is going to have to come to terms
with half of him chose to die
right which we've kind of a little bit
are getting into that you can talk about
it all day long this is something that
will come from the inside out
okay and by the way for those people who
are into who are suicidologists who are
into studying this I understand that
what I just said him choosing to die is
a controversial I don't mean for it to
be that way but for my 13 year old my
dad made a decision to not he'd rather
be gone than with me he'd rather be gone
than know me any further because 13 year
olds are very like them eye Centric
so
he's got to make he's got to come to
terms with that and he's also has to
come to terms with practicing autonomy
the world ripped his dad from him
at the age of five and he his father the
guy he's with there I mean I'm sorry his
dad every day that he's with he loves
and all that but that lingering who am I
and I want to get to know myself is gone
and the world took that from him and so
he's feels powerless is what I'm getting
at and so him practicing I have some
tiny bit of autonomy I get to choose but
my body says no I get to honor that and
you as his mom play
Cornerstone role in teaching him nope
your body is correct and we're going to
honor what that body says now this is a
this is a
this is a tightrope to walk because
sometimes his body's gonna make I don't
want to go to school and I don't want to
go to work and I don't you know I want
to smoke weed or whatever and then
you're gonna be like I don't really care
what your body says you're not doing
that right so there's going to be a
balance here but when it comes to
relationships I would really trust his
intuition right now
this means I know a really hard
conversation between you and your
your his his grandparently
yeah and let's be honest
he is their last shred of their lost son
I get it
I totally get it
and I get the devastation and the
Heartbreak so
um here's what we're what we're doing
anytime there's a tragedy like this
you instantly shift from a four to five
year game hope he goes to a good college
and I hope he starts dating somebody
nice you immediately shift from a four
to five year game to a 25-year game
I hope that he is a functioning loving
productive human being at the age of 45
now after his dad died by Suicide that's
the transition we're making okay we're
playing a long long game what does that
mean that means we're gonna have a lot
of Grace because he's gonna really
struggle when he's 15 16 17. we're just
going to know that going in it's gonna
be tough he's gonna be feeling
untethered and you're going to be
thinking he's got a dad here that loves
him who's been here since he was a
you're right and he has a body saying
where's my home where's my home base and
only half of it is there right so he's
going to be flopping around the wind
like a kite we're playing a 25-year game
we're not playing a
are you in the Key Club are you in
Spanish club too we're playing a longer
game than that that's the conversation
you have with grandparents if we force
this now at 13 14 and 15 the moment he
turns 18
you will he'll be a ghost to them
right and so what would be better for
them is to all record him a message to
write him letters
to give him things tangibly that he can
hold not just crappy gifts but actual
connect connections and give those to
him for Christmas and
um and I'm even okay with this
um not okay with lying but I'm okay with
you taking her on the chin this year and
saying hey it's just not a good year for
our family when it comes to travel when
it comes to connectivity it's just not a
good year for us but we will do what we
can in the coming year to see if there's
an opportunity to make this thing work
okay can I ask you one more question of
course
okay so one thing that he pointed out to
me is that he really doesn't like and I
don't know if I should be the one to
express this to them or if I should wait
on him to come into it on his own
because I feel like maybe it'll change
but at this point he says it really
bothers him when he goes to see them or
talk to them and anything that happens
they say oh your dad was just like that
um yeah she says to me like he feels no
connection because he has zero memory of
him right and so he's like it's like
they're telling me I'm like a stranger
and it makes them uncomfortable
absolutely I don't want him to be
uncomfortable so I feel like I should
say something but I don't know how to do
it in a way that's like loving and not
insulting to them yeah I
um that's gonna switch in two three four
or five years it's going to be the
deepest honor in his life to know that
there was somebody else that walked
steps before him
okay and so this is it may be something
you mentioned if you're having this
conversation about hey this just isn't a
good year
um for us or little Charlie's not doing
well this year
um or he's we're gonna just circle up
and have a really intimate quiet family
Christmas
um and so this isn't going to be a good
time
if that if if somebody in that family
were to say who you're talking to
yeah we understand it's super hard on
that little boy and we miss him and but
I understand that he's 13 and this is
just a tough time for him
that might be a good moment to say hey
one thing to keep in mind when he does
come around again
um references to his dad you walk like
him you laugh just like him that make
him really uncomfortable and I want him
to have a relationship with y'all down
the road
um but I just want y'all to know that
he's mentioned that that might be a good
moment for that otherwise
that's a thing between y'all too and if
he was my son and he was 14 and he'd
made the decision I want to go do
Christmas with my with my one day with
the extended family the people I share
genetics with down the line
I would let him know hey people are
going to make comments about how you
laugh like your dad or your your birth
father they're gonna make just just know
that just know that that's their way of
telling you that they love you and that
they are glad that you're there and you
you see what I'm saying it's a way of
teaching him hey they're not trying to
be ugly they're just trying to honor the
loss of the person that they loved but
I think it's important for everybody to
note that's not his job his job isn't to
heal everybody else
he's a 13 year old boy he can't carry
the grief of his extended family it's
their job to do their healing on their
own and then hopefully down the road
there's a way that people can we can
honor everybody can honor each other
right
um
and I guess here's a good point to say
if he never comes around to them I
as he doesn't have to as far as I'm
concerned
if next year and the year after and the
year after he just does not have a
connection and does not want to go spend
a holiday with strangers I'm okay with
that I'm going to let him have that
autonomy
there will come a day when he wants to
know about his Heritage and he wants to
know where he's from and we want to
preserve those relationships the trail
the path to those relationships so that
when he comes a knocking he has a safe
place to go he's interested in going not
he decides I'm gonna bury my Heritage
because I don't want to know because I
hate those people
that's a recipe for all kinds of
psychological dysfunction down the road
so you're good good good Mom God
Almighty he's lucky to have you and I'm
so sorry about your loss um I know even
even though it's been a long time
holidays just bring all that stuff up
have the hard conversation with
the other family
tell your son that you honor his wishes
and that when his gut tells him that you
want to um teach him that his body is
telling him the truth and the body says
no let's listen to it
but he still has to go to school and
make his bed right